at the federal government we know this
has put migrants on planes when they
cross over the border and then sent them
all over the country so de Santa said
hey I'm just doing the same thing that
they've been doing so here is our black
lesbian press secretary Corrine
Jean-Pierre getting called out at the
White House for doing the same thing
that the Sanders did this is apparently
um you know he said it was essentially
no different than what the federal
government has done in sending you know
flights in the middle of the night so we
are offering Solutions that's what the
Biden Harris Administration has been
doing since day one including on the
first day putting forth a comprehensive
immigration reform to deal with this
issue God she's incredible like it's not
I don't know what questions she's
answering it doesn't matter she just has
a we offering solutions they say words
to get to the period in the sentence so
the sentence is over and they've done
nothing but take you on a ride of BS